When you go to space, you look back at the planet from that orbital vantage point,...
...the Earth is this little blue marble.
The perspective that you get from that vantage point cognitively changes you.
I think the thing that changes your thinking in space...
...is that you're doing something that only a very small number of people have done.
In the history of human space flight,...
...there's only been like 500 people that have had this opportunity to go off the planet.
And now, you're one of them.
You get much calmer when you come back from space...
...because the things that you thought were a big deal are no longer a big deal.
These things that are happening day-to-day...
...like a hangnail or tripping or someone cutting you off in traffic,...
...it pales in comparison to the experience that you have had.
Space transformed me to think about how do we get that next generation...
...to take my seat and go off somewhere else and do much better things.